[Music]
now like many others i spent years and
years waiting for a live-action version
of sandman the graphic novel is
something that's always been close to my
heart and just after i finished uni i
ended up getting a minimum wage job in
his shop working about 30 hours a week
this gave me about 800 pounds a month
and after bills and food came out i was
left with a little bit to spend on
comics now at the time dc was slowly in
the process of rolling out their
gigantic sandman omnibuses these came in
at about 80 pound each which was a lot
of money for me at the time however i
saved and saved and saved up for them
and eventually bought the first volume i
burned through it in the space of a
weekend and even though it had the work
hyped up to me quite a lot i was still
completely blown away by it i then saved
up and bought the second volume and the
book just seemed to get better and
better now sadly at the time due to my
money issues i had to sell both books
but they've always held a special place
next to my heart and every time i hear
about sandman i think back to those days
of when i was living week to week
enjoying the simple things in life
hearing that netflix was adapting a live
action version of the comic really
piqued my interest and in case you don't
know bring it to the screen has been a
massive endeavor for the creators if you
listen to the podcast best movies never
made then you'll know they did a big
breakdown of the original script and
it's clear there's been several people
trying to get this off the ground
initially pitched as a movie it's now a
10 episode tv show that stays very
faithful to the comics nowhere is this
scene more than in episode 6 which
adapts the sound of her wings and also
doll's house part 4. these are two of
the best issues in the entire run and
the reason that netflix put them
together is because they both study life
and death in the first part of the entry
we watch his dream joins his sister
death as she goes about her daily
routine of meeting people after they
pass away the second part follows
morpheus as he meets a man who's been
granted immortality on the same date
every 100 years and the first of these
always struck a chord with me when i was
reading it death is something that we
must all face and it's still a subject
that we know very little about people
spend their entire lives living with
faith or in the absence of it and we all
have our own thoughts and beliefs on
what will be waiting for us even with
the idea of the afterlife it's rather
death is ever welcomed and many of us
hate to think about it because of the
anxiety it brings however the comic and
episodes show us that it's just another
part of life that we all have to go
through now why gaming broke the mold is
because he completely reinvented the
personification of death gone was the
classic depiction of the grim reaper and
here we met a young friendly character
that was based on cinnamon hadley she
came across in an unassuming manner and
barely made an entrance with her in
dreams simply sitting down together and
talking it's the perfect way to
introduce the character and it's brought
across to the episode expertly when we
catch the pair in a park together one
section that always stuck out to me in
the comics was when death would tell
people that their time was up and they
desperately begged for more she then
informed them that they got the same as
everyone else they got a lifetime it's a
line that's always stuck out to me and
whenever i've heard of people passing
away it's something i've remembered
whether the character she comes across a
young old or in the prime of their lives
they all got a lifetime although this
line doesn't get brought up in the
episode itself it's clearly brought
across thematically here we watch death
and morpheus go on a beat for beat
retread of the journey that they did in
the source material first she catches a
boy's football who's not really looking
too deeply into his surroundings then
they go to an old man with a violin
before journeying to a baby as someone
who's just had kids this scene hits me
even harder now and i can't imagine how
devastating it would be for something
like this to happen to a parent it truly
shows how tragic that death could be and
how it affects everyone around us
however whilst that would normally be
depressing what the episode is really
telling us is how precious and short
that life is you can be out with a
person you love one day and in the next
moment end up dying through no real
fault of your own it's really
heartbreaking stuff but in the end it's
just a process of the universe that
we're all part of although some of the
deaths feel like they have no purpose
the true meaning behind everything is to
find something that we love living for
there's a great shot after the violinist
dies where dream stares at a photo of
him in his quartet and it showcases some
of the happiest moments in his life it's
very bittersweet and almost like a final
swan song for the character before he
goes on in the next stage of life and
watching characters beg to let their
wife know one last thing it's really
heartbreaking and yeah it shows how
devastating that loss can be i think i
cried like 10 times well there was some
dust in the room to be fair but yeah
every single one of the deaths felt
impactful what the comic and episode do
perfectly is that they make you
contemplate your own life and death and
it makes you introspectively think about
all the things that matter we all die
one day and this is an excellent way to
show things from the perspective of a
character who's been tasked with taking
us to the great beyond like dream death
thought about leaving her post because
she couldn't keep doing this due to how
devastating it was however much like the
people whose lives we see snuffed out
she found some form of purpose and also
enjoyment death decided to give them a
kind word and a friendly face and she
saw the other side of her existence and
how to make the most of it seeing the
pair go on their journey as they take
the dead as beautiful and it reminds us
of what death is really about now this
is murdered by the second part of the
entry which follows death and dream as
they grant immortality to a stranger
though this is part of the dollhouse
storyline it's titled men of good
fortune and it centers around hob he
lives in the 1300s a century filled with
a black death where you are lucky to
live past 35. he believes that no one
needs to die and that we do because we
haven't ingrained into us that this is
the way of the world being a pessimist
dream believes that he will beg for
death but hub defies all expectations
and to all the highs and lows he still
wants to stay alive this is a character
that truly goes on a roller coaster ride
and he shows all the ups and downs of
life hobb is a complicated character
that becomes fixated on his fortune to
the point that when he loses it it
leaves him completely broken what hub
truly represents to me though is how far
humanity has come and all the ups and
downs that have been a part of it he
truly is a history lesson that gets
involved in the printing press sees
william shakespeare and a lot more now i
love the way that we also see the
overall emotion of humanity repeat
through the ages there's calls for
revolution people working on the doll
and us just telling jokes now though we
are the same at our very core hob also
showcases the potential that we have we
are a very complicated species with a
past that's often shied away from but in
order to understand what it truly means
to be human we have to shine light on
the darkness hob also faces the same
losses that we do too and being an
immortal means he sees death first hand
and also faces the rune of his business
however he still bounces back and he
very much represents dreams need to find
companionship with humanity robert calls
him lonely which is very much a
characteristic that he struggles with
throughout the entire run like hob he's
an immortal who only ever really
interacts with others when they go to
the dream world and having been betrayed
by humanity in the past he struggles to
trust others this has pushed him away
and he believes that he's better off
alone however hobbs states that like all
of us he needs a connection though
initially dream protests against this
and denies that he could ever be friends
with immortal he ends up returning at
the end to continue their conversation
dream was trapped for so long that it
made him truly re-examine what things
meant to him and he realized that he and
hobb had a friendship that many would
never understand we as people can often
be like this as well where we push
others away from us who often mean the
most but this shows that there is a way
to mend friendships if one acts with
openness and also kindness i love hob
saying that people are always better
than you think they are and it shows
that we have the potential within us for
greatness
watching the pair meet for the final
time also cements how far we've all come
and it makes you think of what's coming
for the future really makes me wish i
could see that meeting 100 years from
now and hob truly makes us wonder what
it would be like to live forever coupled
together these two parts are perfect
summations of life and death with us
seeing through all the characters what
it truly means to be human it's
definitely my favorite episode in the
series and it perfectly recaptures the
comic that i fell in love with in my
other life i hope you had fun with us
talking about why we enjoyed it so much
and i'd of course love to hear your
comments below on exactly what you think
we are in a competition right now and
giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
you pick the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one on
screen right now if that's you then
message me on twitter heavyspoilers if
you want someone emails to watch them
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the series which will be linked on
screen right now we go over all the
easter eggs in it explain the ending and
also just talk about our general
thoughts on it hope to see you over
there right after this and if not thanks
for sitting through the video you take
care of yourself and i'll see you in a
hundred years time peace